for the last six months I've been
working on my own nft project
cryptozoo dot Co it's a really fun game
that makes you money I lost around fifty
thousand dollars in cryptos I lost forty
thousand dollars five hundred thousand
dollars Australian I'm telling you just
a picture there's nothing I could do
with it wait you can't even
[Music]
um crypto Zoo where our our lead
developer uh took the code that he made
fled to Switzerland actually fled to
Switzerland and like held it hostage for
a million dollars you never literally
never gave me anything not all ever any
policy you know five percent tokens and
a million dollars never we never really
never paid wait a second who's Eddie I
thought that all of this was Logan Paul
what's this random guy doing in Logan
Paul's project and who is he who is
Eddie Ivan
begin answering the question of who
Eddie is I decided to take a deep dive
I started by looking through all the
news articles I could on Eddie where I
found out he graduated from MIT and from
there became a data scientist and cyber
security expert and used that technical
background to win a Super Bowl for the
Eagles and there were videos on him too
which all painted him as brilliant and
extremely accomplished yes hi my name is
Eddie ivanez and I'm a father of three
um lead developer here at crypto Zoo as
a teenager he successfully hacked AOL
from his bedroom he continued to pursue
computer science until attending MIT he
was then recruited out to work for a
government agency in cyber security
developing software that reverse
Engineers location of known government
and terrorist threats we started with
the federal government and you started
off really tracking criminals would burn
the phones and all
honestly after this whole search I felt
more confused than ever if Eddie's such
an amazing guy why didn't he pay
developers and is he really the Puppet
Master behind crypto zoo or is it
someone else honestly I felt like at
this point I needed a drink and I needed
to ask for help
not good
oh well I'm confused about this Eddie
Ibanez guy
comes out of nowhere with this crypto
Zoo Story and everything about him I
find seems great so
what's the problem well everything's not
great everything about this guy just
seems too perfect he's an MIT grad he
worked for the military he even claims
he won a Super Bowl why would that guy
work for Logan Paul I don't know but I
can find out he said his name is Eddie
Ibanez I think he goes by Eduardo
technically but
wait what are you doing
just looking around
and done well what'd you find a few red
flags a couple of misdemeanors oh
few court cases I'll send them over
he got sued by his landlord for not
paying rent sued by his credit card
company for not paying his bill you can
skip that stuff I just need whatever's
relevant to cryptozoo well that's
basically it other than hold on
no wait I did find something
look look at this
what's this it's from a paper in Philly
I barely picked it up this reporter says
Eddie's entire story is fake wait what
yeah the whole Eddie Ibanez character
this guy Adam Rob investigated it he
says it's a lie I gotta find this guy
send me his info I got some calls to
make up coffee that's right ladies and
gentlemen we met up with Adam Rob the
reporter who's been investigating Eddie
Ibanez for a while now and I wanted to
know what did Adam think of him when
they first met I wasn't quite sure what
to make of him based on what I knew
about him he was a MIT grad who went on
to work for the CIA and defense
department and I didn't want to waste
his time and it wasn't long after I sat
down that I realized he was wasting my
time can you tell me about some of the
lies Eddie told you Eddie has told me
so many lies over the course of my two
interviews with him and the first lie he
told me is probably the oldest lie that
he's told so many people which is that
he's an orphan I first realized Eddie
might be lying to me when I went home
the next day and Googled Eddie ibanez's
family I found a video of Eddie and his
wife making a rice pudding on a fox and
friends segment on Fox News and Eddie's
wife Jackie explained that she learned
the recipe from Eddie's mother so in the
picture you've got Jackie Ibanez you
know her along with her husband Eddie
and her two little girls you love rice
pudding why is this a family recipe okay
so Eddie's mom made this rice pudding
once wait Eddie's mom I thought Eddie
was an orphan oh it turns out the only
problem with that is that not only does
his mom exist she's alive and in his
life and it turns out it wasn't just
Adam that heard this story either he
told it a lot did you ever meet his
mother or his parents I
did he ever tell you he was an orphan
yes
how did he square that with you
he told me he was orphan and
[Music]
he told me he was an orphan and then I
met his mother is quite the string of
words but as insane as these lies are
let's be real it doesn't explain why
cryptozu failed but the next lies kind
of do because part of Eddie's story is
also that he went to MIT where he was
recruited to the CIA and it's part of
why he was so attractive as a lead
developer all the wild experiences that
he had had but it's just not true I
emailed the MIT registrar's office and I
asked if Eddie Ibanez attended the
school and they confirmed in absolute
terms that he never attended MIT that's
right the whole orphan to MIT origin
story it wasn't true and Eddie's whole
back story from here kind of falls apart
as well how could he have been recruited
to a government agency out of MIT if he
never went to MIT
if this is all seeming crazy to you you
might ask yourself who would believe all
this and this is where Eddie shines he
kind of had a gift for getting people to
believe in the lies he told especially
super rich and powerful people for some
reason like take for instance this story
him winning the Super Bowl for the
Philadelphia Eagles he managed to
convince the owner of the New York
Yankees that it was true Barry clarberg
who completely bought into it without
question and told the same story later
in a college seminar let's jump right
into the work that you did for the
Philadelphia Eagles which led to a led
to a Super Bowl championship led to you
getting a Super Bowl ring tell us
exactly what your job was to do for them
and how it would work out no sure thing
so first off they they said like uh we
don't know where to put you but uh and
then the sports science guy was the one
guy he's like hey I got some data I'm
interested so uh so we took in his data
and then we found out that these players
uh what happens is it's like a player as
they run around uh they get a certain
fatigue levels so if you think if you
ever played Street Fighter the video
game there's like a red bar at the top
and every time you get hit that red part
goes down until you die right so then
we're trying to figure out kind of what
that is for a player and on an injury
level right there's an injury part of it
gets uh gets knocked down and that gets
killed this is insane he convinced an
owner of the Yankees that he won a Super
Bowl by turning Sports athletes into
Street Fighter characters
and of course none of it's true the
Philadelphia Eagles responded to a fact
check saying he never worked for their
player analysis team not only that the
Eagles also said that Eddie did try to
do an in-person presentation in March of
2018 but that was already a month after
the Eagles had already won the Super
Bowl and also they didn't hire him
because of course not meaning there's no
way this story is true and yet he's
convinced people at the highest levels
of sports that it is and this is where
we get back to crypto zoo of course
because it's how he got involved with
that project remember Jeff Levin Logan's
manager who he spoke to last time well
he also spoke to Adam Rob and when he
told him the reasons he liked Eddie they
sounded very familiar and did he tell
you I guess kind of like about like
working with the NFL and that kind of
stuff and the whole yeah like his time
in the CIA and all that
you did and it was interesting it was
like
this is wild you know like that's pretty
cool but he's once again he's humble and
he's he's not like ever bragging or
anything like that wait wait but but he
is bragging he literally made it all up
the CIA NFL stories aren't true how
could that not be bragging but that's
the impression Eddie gave off but that's
not all because Eddie didn't just use
made up stories to get in with the
crypto Zoo team he also used his other
connections his real millionaire and
billionaire friends that he's managed to
gain with all these fake stories and
some of them vouched for him people like
Chris Burch and Todd Morley and what was
the thing that kind of like sold you and
Eddie was it the fact that like Chris
and Todd and people like that kind of
like have backed him in the past and
like I didn't think he was down to earth
cool humble guy okay who's been who's
been super successful they're trying to
do with an agenda and he's just kind of
like hey look I'm super smart in what I
know and I have amazing relationships
through business that I've done it's
incredible I mean how does this guy keep
getting away with it honestly it's
baffling but I've got to say up till now
everyone's been fooled sort of fair and
square on the same grounds but I found
out cryptozoo did have an advantage that
could have saved them all this trouble
the whole time so a month before the
launch of cryptozoo I got on the phone
with Jeff Levin Logan Paul's manager and
after he spoke fondly of Eddie and his
work I confronted him about some of
Eddie's lies including how he didn't
work for the NFL Jeff told me he doesn't
know much about the NFL but he knows
about the business world and Chris Burch
and Todd Morley vouch for Eddie and so
Jeff and Logan were going to continue
working with him have you ever verified
that anything Eddie said about himself
is true we've verified that it's true
yeah yeah we definitely talk to people
okay and his friends and you know and
people that he said he has relationships
with which we've confirmed them for sure
okay because I had trouble with some of
that like with the NFL like saying that
like no we've never worked with him and
that kind of thing but but you've had
the NFL saying that yeah
like who in the NFL the the comms teams
for the Eagles and the uh dolphins and
then the
um people specifically that he named the
piece that you worked with
got it um I don't know necessarily the
football stuff okay you know I don't
have relationships in the football World
sure but the business world you know we
definitely
like topic Chris and they backed him
correct wait a second this means at
minimum Jeff knew about Eddie's
background beforehand or part of it and
still decided to go with him this is
just unbelievable willful stupidity and
since Jeff is Logan's manager I assume
him and the team should have known about
this as well but still they went forward
with it even though they knew this stuff
before launch now I started to reach out
for comments about this because
obviously this is a huge deal but when I
did I got a call from somebody new
someone with a different perspective
that I hadn't heard from before Jake the
crypto King he's been involved with some
of Logan's projects in the past like
Pokemon for example he was called the
Collectibles Guru a few years ago
nowadays he goes by crypto King and he's
an advisor for the crypto Zoo project so
let's add him to the conspiracy board
but the question is what did he have to
say I took a call with him and he mostly
wanted to talk off the Record but when I
pressed him he was willing to at least
put one thing on the record for me right
one more thing about Eddie before we get
off of him we actually
got this reason it felt in my opinion
okay because I don't want it to ever be
thought that Logan's the reason it felt
he's not Logan wasn't smart enough for
what he tried to build and then when it
was built and was failing didn't have
the ability to correct it and to save
face and reputation it was more
convenient to pull out than to be
associated with a family project that
the devrock so um I could put that one
sentence on the record well that is
certainly emphatic crypto King says it's
all Eddie's fault and this is a nice
neat theory for us you know Eddie ruined
everything because Yeah Eddie is a liar
so it does seem to explain how these
developers got screwed but this Theory
doesn't fit all the facts because Eddie
was kicked off the team months ago and
still the game is not working despite
Logan claiming they were going to go
back and fix all the problems again
retroactively working to make that make
these projects right and it just takes
time bro it just takes time development
takes time working backwards to fix
things which isn't ideal but also this
project will speak for itself and now
you know we're working backwards to try
to to try to fix it this just hasn't
happened even a year from launch the
game just doesn't exist what's worse is
the newest Dev team who came on after
Eddie just quit and one of the reasons
was they hadn't been paid for over a
month I know that this because Logan's
team is leakier than the Titanic and
someone told me that but we also have
blockchain evidence this is Jeff paying
Black Ops the company they hired out on
July 19th they were supposed to redo all
this work it's confirmed by their leader
skip talking about a first monthly
payment on that day but after that
there's nothing until they quit on
September 26th in a post called Art
departure from cryptozoo now I do have
to say it does look like they were
eventually paid but only a day after
they quit and this is just the same
problem as before slightly different
nobody can pay these devs on time and
investors end up getting nothing and so
I can't buy into the idea that Eddie's
at fault for everything because when
Eddie was gone they had a lot of the
same problems now it was only at the
point that this Dev team quit block ops
that things really took a turn because
if the Titanic was leaking before now it
was sinking and everyone basically gave
up hope you know from every direction I
started getting messages from all the
investors who felt betrayed who up to
this point were holding on to hope now
they felt defeated they felt tricked by
the crypto Zoo team who had fed them
promise after promise and they were sick
of it he was never in each other or
anything never apologized or told us
anything things didn't work out things
didn't work out we all get that but to
continuously lie lead people on
hype people up to put more money in all
all the while in the background things
are going down things are hitting the
fan and you've left us holding the bag I
know it was my decision and I did my
research but I I believe nobody has to
lose money in this way and that's when a
whistleblower stepped forward and
decided enough was enough they decided
to leak me messages Team messages from
the crypto Zoo team from all the way
back in the beginning when they thought
of this idea all the way up to launch
and seeing that it changed everything
because all of a sudden I got a lot of
new information remember how Jake the
crypto King said Eddie was the only
problem well a year ago he was saying
something very different on the day of
launch he said this to the group Logan
you stole 40 million in tokens from me
you are a scam artist you are a liar and
you betrayed your own community you
aren't that guy Logan replies oh Jake
trust me bro I am that guy
at these ascending market caps and that
it's not like I was trying to run a
project it's like I put 250 000 into a
project plus six months of time and the
founder never did anything he said he
was going to do and then hired a bunch
of devs that didn't know what they were
going to do and every time I gave advice
the advice was
there is nothing illegal about that
arguable the rest that oriented to me
was ethically deep wrong and illegal